e aí ainda show gravado com você e não
porque porque o brasil é o brasil
eita nessa copa aconteceu coisa quem
assistiu junto à da rone neste jogo a
devon na cor de deus não de volta é o
seguinte ela não entende muito porque a
seleção do tempo delas é diferente a
seleção de agora ela não sabe o nome do
jogador que é estranho vai de copa ele é
o oscar romário que não parece que a mãe
da gente tinha muita gente é o seguinte
não sabe onde joga noturna ela sabe onde
ninguém é a pessoa que é lançado o nome
e mael o jogo todo e vai vai vai
marmanjo leão daniel vai ganhar um
autógrafo neymar mãe agora está aí o
neymar vai matar campo neymar mãe está é
o que vale mas meu o lema eu não
aguentava mais me falando em alemão era
mãe falei nada que algo em torno de uma
televisão do carro muito se sabe o
assunto deve ser sobre a imagem filme
manô bem avisada de gopal usamos aqui no
intervalo fui comer aquele cachorro
quente show é dividido pelo senhor além
da rua a rua onde eu já a decorrer os
jogadores de portugal portugal que tem
um grande astro cristiano ronaldo
jogador do real madrid é real madrid que
é rival do barcelona onde joga o menino
neymar jogar muito ainda bate pro gol ea
multi mais gente eu falei de assistir o
jogo do ano a avó e assistido a da onu a
gente se você não sabe que assistiu o
jogo a voga um lado e assistir com a mãe
do lar vai beber é o neymar
só conheço nem mais o oscar neymar que
paulo pede fai vai em massa é o romário
é romário e seu neymar romário que tocou
pra ele vai escalar neymar que o fred
também né
a construção desse estádio através de
mapas são pedro e no meio campo aí ou é
o fred no último jogo do brasil fred
correu sete quilômetros valeu a espera
gandula ocorreu 12 infelizmente
infelizmente foi eliminado eu nesse jogo
da alemanha já fui assim assim eu sabia
ao meio ambiente a pb
mas desse jeito eu tô sendo armamento
assim brasil brasileiro
o som só o som para acordar galera só
para nos acordar e vai assistir e utah
ó
orientar o prejuízo moral brasil vai
mais barata rato já pagaram
será que nada anda da bahia dá né
embora um bom nessa vai
o bota cota também já vi muito time já
aconteceu muito muito já vi muito o time
e estou indo do mundo
tudo que o amapá tem muito time virar
desse jeito cortado enquanto a 0 que 4 a
0 e 4 a 0
o caminho não só sou sou super a ler
olhar chance no paraná onde a par do que
pelé de messi mim gente
a vida é feita de desafios e sons para
que possamos no pantanoso objetivo agora
wafa de efeito vamos ser refletidas no
resto do dia enquanto formos na na casa
do pedreiro
o espeto de pau mas valendo 12 gás na
ásia de que um voando eu quero que você
comente eu quero que você comente aqui
em baixo o que você mais o jogo nesta
copa do mundo e é claro você vê e claro
se você tiver postado o vídeo vai curtir
do vítima dando banho assim ó deixado
pelo menos um espanto dele só financiar
não gostei que você me ajuda muito é a
primeira vez que está assistindo um
vídeo meu sempre quem escrevesse bem que
marquei com escrever se inscreveu toda
vez que o rendimento no cabelo
valeu e na ebi pé